well congratulations on a hundred
episodes uh of swat this is so exciting
you know when you first joined this
series do you ever think you'd get to
this point or was this the goal
yeah i mean no no you mean you hope you
know you'd like to thank you like a
whole bunch more more
that's me after a couple drinks talking
mess i like it
um no you you you never know you i mean
i've been i've been blessed to be in
this game professionally 28 years and
you couldn't have told me i mean nobody
in my family and friends had ever acted
you know my dream was to be a
professional baseball player i was a
communication major honestly nobody
believes this when i say it because i'm
shamar mf moore when i'm talking mass i
was a really shy i was a really shy kid
and sport
[Music]
oh and and uh so fast forward you know i
took some chances i was communication
major i was in theater arts mind the
whole reason i got into acting was
because i thought it would help me get
over being shy but i had no idea that i
was gonna make it professionally and uh
and then fast forward things happen so
no 28 years and going from young arrests
to criminal lines
eight years on ynr 11 years on
criminal minds now five years you know
as an actor you hope they like you you
they hope they pick you uh you hope you
get a pilot you hope it gets picked up
then you it gets picked up and you hope
that you do a good job you hope there's
another season so to have the success
and the journey that i've had
uh
from 1994 to now and now the 100
episodes on the squad no i pitch myself
and i i piss myself i and i'll never
take it for granted but i'm so proud
of what i've accomplished but what we
have accomplished as a show that goes
back to all the other shows met some
really great people some not so great
people but you you live and you learn
but we each place there's it's like a
family and we really have a swat family
and and we know we're making a fun
thrill ride of a show that is grounded
takes on takes on uh
grounded topics so even though we're a
lot of fun there's a lot of heart
there's a lot of humanity
and there's a lot of reality in
so it's there's so many variables that
i'm just proud to be a part of yeah you
know it's pretty cool you know when you
you name the shows that you've been a
part of each show has had a pretty die
hard fan base swat definitely has such a
loyal fan base what's it like having
that kind of support year after year but
especially on a show like swat
i call them my homies my fans and my
baby girls that's what i call them and
uh just uh they've shown me so much love
i mean i love what i do for them but if
nobody's gonna watch you then and then
they're not gonna pick you to do it so
there's been you know i just love the
support that i've gotten through the
years they've watched me grow they've
watched me grow as an actor they've
watched me grow as a man
um
and uh
they've given me confidence with that
support and you know that that i need to
keep going keep trying keep you trying
to grow so um that's cool but you know
the fanfare
you know
people still get me on the streets for
being still a baby daddy on young and
restless and
they still they love they love hearing
me say baby girl because that originated
on criminal minds and criminal minds is
this like
still it's like i feel like it's more
popular now than when we were all doing
it um you know with the help of tick
tock and everything else i mean my soul
trained they're britain i'm popular i'm
52 years old in a month and and soul
train was before these kids were born
and it's all over tick-tock with my
three and a half dance moves
i don't know if we really want to relive
them days but okay
well i dare you i don't want to relive a
lot of those outfits i was wearing
because
i don't know i think my uh my my stylist
at the time thought i was overgrown
lenny kravitz or something i don't know
it was all wrong um we're back to swat
yeah 100 episodes
uh i'm actually throwing a a wrap party
here at my home when we finish the
season in a few weeks uh just to
celebrate all that we've accomplished
because you know with kobit you haven't
been able to go out you haven't been
able to do anything and so we finally
got permission from the studio and the
network and you know i called dr fauci
and said hey i want to throw a party for
my crew i'm kidding um but uh
i'm gonna throw i'm gonna throw a little
shindig but we're gonna drink a little
bit eat a little bit have a lot of fun
push somebody in the pool play some
games and just
let our hair down and celebrate all that
we've accomplished oh i love it okay so
what can you tease us uh about this
100th episode when it comes to hondo
because i feel like there's a lot going
on with him
yeah yeah no it's big it's our 100th
episode so you know we got to go big you
know so you're going to have our
signature action and i say don't don't
don't be late don't go to the bathroom
go to the fridge one time get what you
need and then sit your butt down and
enjoy the ride the first eight minutes
is some helicopter stunts uh hondo yet
again hanging off a helicopter trying to
do some superhero stuff uh and then it
continues and then hondo gets set up uh
for murder that it looks like he
he went rogue and committed and it's
done through this process
or this concept called deep fake which
i'm still learning about but it's real
to where somehow digitally
uh
in the world of the internet they can
superimpose someone else's likeness on
another person and you think it's that
person but it's fake and so it uh
the media and the department turns on
hondo it looks like he's
committed this murder so hondo's on the
run trying to clear his name and there's
hand-to-hand combat there's car chases
it's dramatic it's intense
honda's pissed off
uh you know that hondo gives you that
that hondo scale that you see
this is shimar hey
what's good what's good and then it's so
good
then there's
[Laughter]
well something that's been fun too for
us is you know we've seen hondo explore
fatherhood how much fun has that been
for you kind of uh exploring that level
when it comes to this character it's
funny i kind of i feel like i feel like
my mother must at one time must have
secretly called all the writers and gave
him all the storylines she wanted me to
do because everything honda's doing i
know my mother wish i was doing in real
life
i love it
though but yeah no fatherhood to see
hondo you know because you know honda's
such a tough guy
and uh you know with that with that
scowl and all that but underneath there
there is a heart there there is a
gentleness uh
there's
there's flaws
uh which i like i don't i don't i don't
want you know it's fun to be a superhero
but but but what's his kryptonite
because that makes him interesting uh so
see him take on family in real life um
you know the stork hasn't flown over my
house yet but that is
that is a bucket list for me to where i
want to you know that is a chapter i
want to live in my life i've
accomplished many things but it would
just be the icing on the cake
um
the day that i become a daddy um so that
that is still a dream of mine uh so
right now i'm doing it on tv
i love that well i have to ask for the
fans since it was announced at criminal
minds like you said more popular than
ever revival coming out is there a
chance that you could potentially make a
guest appearance
well
i missed that part criminal minds
knowing that there's this revival coming
is there a chance to potentially make a
guest appearance i've been hearing about
this off and on for like last year or so
yeah and then i just recently heard that
they made a deal with paramount plus um
and i i think a lot of the returning
cast or my baby girl kirsten banks this
um
uh patrick brewster
uh i think adam rodriguez is coming back
uh i think my papa joe joe montagna
um so you know i'm kind of busy with
swat so a lot of i've gotten a lot of
comments like are you gonna sign on for
criminal minds i'm like uh i work
six days a week
um but uh
would i
if they ask me to return i mean
yeah i would love to play i mean that's
that's family that doesn't go away that
doesn't go away so um if it was a
possibility i would i would sit with my
bosses and say hey you know you got to
give me give me a window to go play with
my
with my gang so yeah i mean i'm just i'm
happy for them that they're bringing it
back because the show the show was so
good to all of us it it changed my life
and the fans loved it um so that comes
back and they want then i just have to
take the hondo beard and kind of tweak
it back into the derrick morgan goatee
and
and be a little nicer than hondo and
smile a little more
and walk in the building go with my baby
girl at your brown sugar in the building
that would be amazing i got the wrap but
always so much fun talking to you and
yeah can't wait to watch this episode
thanks so much all right again you
looking fly
thank you so are you much loved
you